welcome to your mom's house
I'm really gonna get my ass waxed I've
been talking about your ass Savage I
know
or maybe lasered right didn't we talk
about that cuz I don't do either yeah -
my junks mm-hmm I would say go for laser
why not why why keep going back to get
it waxed yeah like just bite the bullet
just really had some breakthrough his
you know thinking about how much more of
my life I could get back with it let's
talk about asshole well I just feel like
there's just so much time spent and
people have told me you know they wax
their asses and it's like one wife two
wipes they're done that's what my world
is something out the bidet it's even
less yeah well I sit there now I'll shit
hit the bidet on you didn't you didn't
hit the button nobody knows what's good
segments this is yeah yeah what's going
on right now
I'll smile
you look like booger at the belching
contest right now you're so proud of
yourself I am so sorry let's go back to
the top so yeah now I just I hit the
water and I just let that spray sit
there but I'll let it spray for you know
a minute I hear you I know yeah no I
literally hear you in the living room
yeah cuz that turlet I can hear what
happens in there yeah that's what really
neat blessing in all our homes is that
I've always been in close proximity to
where you shit yeah so I can hear
everything can you hear the bedroom one
no no just that downstairs the
downstairs one yeah so I hear the water
going for a long time yeah and then you
always come out and you go whoa and then
and then I ignore you you go you're not
gonna ask me yeah you're gonna you're
not gonna ask me and I go how is your
shit you say the same kind of thing to
me though you'll be like don't you want
to know what happened and you play coy
you're wearing your C's around the house
- those fell down does she want to see
your boobs I think do you want a bowl so
I'm serious though do you really want to
get your ass waxed are you being serious
I'm being serious because I've been
thinking about seriously how much time I
spend or like when I'm not home oh my
god I'm not at home and fucking I mean
like it you know public yeah Airport
disaster man it's just mud in there and
it gets into the hair you're smearing
when you wipe you're smashing it into
the hairs how gross it is that hairy ass
what is the hair for why does it even
grow there I don't know because women
don't have hair I mean some I don't yeah
yeah but for you if you're a hunter
together yeah and you're out in the
wilderness you got to cover your asshole
like naked humans I'm saying primitive
man who was out hunting and gathering
women don't need it cuz we're with the
babies in the cave yeah but you're out
there with leopards chasing you you
could sit out on a rock and
snake could crawl right up your ass and
lay eggs this is probably to cover okay
this is this is a real explanation
yeah I'm offering you know I saw this on
Nat Geo
why'd it stop cigarettes asshole have
hair in the next episode well I'm gonna
go reverse that stuff I think you should
so is your butthole hair like your beard
because of that full the whole hair
isn't so crazy it's the inside the crack
she care you know like the cheeks aren't
that hairy when it's like you spread
I've seen it forest yeah you've seen it
well everyone's pretty is it nice not
it's hot yeah it's so hot that's the
other thing I've heard that it really
makes it you know a lot less hot yeah I
mean not sexy hi I know it's gonna stay
sexy
shorter but temperature-wise well cuz
when we did Nikki Glaser's shown not
safe mmm more time out pegging and she's
like you even put your finger up there
and I'm like mmm so hot it's hot steamy
and hairy and Gary it's a gross place
yeah yeah I had a lot of diarrhea today
and you really did the nice thing about
diarrhea with that bad eh is that you
hit that water and you go with paper
later there's nothing left there's
nothing there
I know cuz I had some loose ones too I
say I have I had like a I had like I was
five yeah and the day cleans it right up
total seven I had about a 6.5 yeah yeah
six five it was pretty bad huh it was
pretty bad really loose yeah
loose me sandwich all the way yeah yeah
it kind of made you sit there and go
what is the kind of
just like I just like playing that have
you got any coming those balls